on this Thursday night Ontario's
Premiere doubles down on the Green Belt
Doug Ford protects his housing Minister
but not the protected land at issue
we're going to build homes until people
have the same opportunity that you have
idalia careens into the Carolinas the
damage there as Florida surveys its
Devastation planning a defiant return
despite an evacuation order the resident
was like let me in or else the Convoy
heading to yellowknife's fire zone one
of South Africa's deadliest fires the
desperate escapes and why so many people
couldn't flee the Flames plus acing it
the world record spiked at this
volleyball game
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Fara Nasser good
evening to you and thanks for joining us
Ontario Premier Doug Ford is digging his
heels into the green belt even though
he's facing harsh criticism for using it
to build more homes in the province he's
also standing by his embattled housing
Minister Steve Clark after a report from
the province's Integrity commissioner
found his government's removal of
protected lands was Hasty and deceptive
I'm responsible for everything that
happens in The Province and I always
make sure we hold our caucus and our
ministers accountable to follow the
Mandate that we gave them
well with Ford and Clark have denied any
wrongdoing but they do admit the process
to select the lands which favored
certain developers was flawed now
despite calls from opposition and
Indigenous leaders for Clark to resign
Ford says he will remain part of his
team Eric Sorensen reports on the
Fallout
the Tranquility of Ontario's Greenbelt
has become intensely turbulent for the
Ontario government plans to build
housing in what was protected Green
Space has mired Premier Doug Ford and
his housing Minister Steve Clark in
controversy I'm going to have confidence
in Mr Clark I have confidence in my
other ministers his confidence unshaken
after the Integrity commissioner found
Clark failed to have proper oversight
over decisions to develop the land and
that was after this the housing Minister
ought to have known the key details the
auditor general found certain developers
influence the government to open up the
green belt the housing Minister's Chief
of Staff resigned over that but Ford is
not backing down I have a message to all
the developers get the shovels on the
ground get started the green belt forms
a horseshoe around the greater Toronto
area it is here in this part of the
Greenbelt Northeast of Toronto that the
controversy is centered duffin's Rouge
agricultural preserve is 4 700 Acres of
farmland and natural habitat as many as
30 30 000 housing units could be built
here it's a small number in Premier
Ford's overall plan to build 1.5 million
homes across Ontario but it would
forever change this region there's major
environmental impacts Kim Humphries
lives near the proposed development and
opposes Ford he does not have to develop
on this land that serves lots of area
that can be developed and this is not
the place to be the provincial Green
Party leaders says Ford is favoring
developers over what Ontario residents
want people want Housing Solutions they
want homes they can afford in
communities they want to live in they
want the premier to put ordinary people
ahead of wealthy insiders the premier is
not listening to critics this green bald
everyone's making such a big deal about
it's a sliver compared to the big
problem we have the big problem is Ford
sees it is creating enough housing so
he's going to build even in the green
belt Eric Sorensen Global News Pickering
Ontario
Premier Doug Ford spent most of his
press conference in Toronto today
playing defense with reporters but when
Global's Queens Park correspondent Colin
Demello questioned him over whether he
will hold his own cabinet to account
Ford went on the offense
what people are seeing here after this
Integrity commissioner and auditor
General's report is nothing but
incompetence right from the chief of
staff who decided to rush through a
process to the housing Minister who
looked away because he thought it was
going to be too politically sensitive to
a premier who directed his housing
minister to open up the green belt after
promising ontarians that you would never
touch the green belt so so I'll take but
premium at what point do do you take
personal responsibility here and how are
people to have trust in your leadership
well thank you for that calling and I'm
sure you just walked down the street
from your home that you have a home but
you know many people don't have a home
calling well Colin guess what we're
going to build homes we're going to
build homes until people have the same
opportunity that you have you have a
nice home down the street but guess what
there's hundreds of thousands of people
that don't have your opportunity Colin
clearly a lot of frustration in that
exchange talk to us about the kind of
pressure the premier seems to be under
right now
well that exchange far as emblematic of
the fact that Premier Doug Ford is under
an immense amount of pressure the green
belt Scandal has been sustaining itself
for the past three weeks the opposition
here at Queen's Park calls Premier Doug
Ford corrupt he's been losing support in
public opinion polls let's not forget
the RCMP is considering whether to
launch a full-scale police investigation
all of that led us to today housing
Minister Steve Clark addressed the media
for the first time saying he takes
responsibility but did not tender his
resignation Premier Doug Ford also
accepted responsibility but did not ask
for Steve Clark's resignation it led to
Growing questions about what the premier
means when he says the buck stops with
him that's when the premier launched
into his attack on journalists claiming
that he was feeling attacked the premier
later apologized for that exchange it is
all boiling down to this far here in
Ontario there's lots of responsibility
being taken but little accountability to
go along with it
Colin Demello in Toronto thanks for your
coverage Colin
thank you
idalia ripped across the Carolinas today
with very high winds and heavy rain
a near record tide breached Charleston's
historic sea wall and it left many
downtown buildings swamped with salt
water in Florida people are mopping up
and they're assessing the damage from
the powerful storm that left behind an
1100 kilometer path of Destruction at
least one person was killed in Georgia
President Joe Biden says he's going to
visit the Gulf Coast on Saturday to see
it all for himself Jackson prosco
reports on the monster cleanup
in the Florida town of Horseshoe Beach
the damage stretches in every direction
residents are returning home to see if
there's anything left what matters is
what I'm holding right here
it's just material stuff
hurricane Adalia roared through the town
first with wind then tremendous storm
surge
this was the moment a manufactured home
sank under the water incredibly there
are still properties left standing I'm
feeling great the house is still here up
and down an area known as Florida's Big
Bend there's an anxious wait for the
waters to recede our house is sitting up
under three four foot of water
overwhelmed I would say would be the
really the only kind of way to describe
it um
it's it's just ruined I mean everything
in there is kind of lost
hidalia was a storm for the agents the
most powerful hurricane to hit the
region in more than a century tracking
across Florida Georgia and the Carolinas
tens of thousands have no power they
face weeks of cleanup ahead all the
water started coming up through the
floor it wasn't even through the front
door just every corner of the house
through the floorboards all throughout
the house the entire house early
estimates suggest at least 20 billion
dollars in damage but it's too soon to
know for sure you did see structural
damage to buildings I saw roofs torn off
of businesses we saw other types of of
hurricane damage there's no question
what is clear is that Adalia could have
been far worse but most residents heeded
warnings and left before landfall a
decision that likely saved lives in the
face of a powerful storm
Jackson prosco Global News
officials in the Northwest Territories
are placing the reopening of Yellowknife
on hold as concerns grow over high winds
fueling wildfires near some major
highways more than 240 fires are still
burning across the territory pushing the
government to extend its state of
emergency until at least September 11th
several highways remain completely
closed with many others under a road
advisory that means long stretches of
Road including the main way in and out
of the territorial Capital could close
with little or no notice in the coming
days of course this pause is added to
the growing frustration felt by tens of
thousands forced to flee their homes but
officials say it's still too dangerous
to return and they're warning that
anyone who tries to could face serious
consequences Jamie Dahl reports
two weeks hunkered down in campers and
on cots in hotel rooms and hostels and
Convention centers thousands of
kilometers from home many evacuees from
the Northwest Territory say they've had
their fill definitely ready to go home
and be in my own house and kind of get
some normalcy in our lives again the
evacuation it's unfortunate but I think
we're ready to go home but the fires
that forced them out are still too
stubborn the wind too unpredictable
while the situation has stabilized some
and Yellowknife the territory's one main
artery is still in the fire zone you're
not flying in this it's very difficult
to drive in this there is the likelihood
that Highway 1 will be compromised both
in Alberta and in the Northwest
Territories do due to fires in the area
people are getting impatient on
Wednesday RCMP said it received
information a group of about 50 Vehicles
is planning a convoy back and that it
would not be stopping at checkpoints we
understand people are frustrated but
this is not the way to deal with that
frustrate everyone's working very hard
to get people home
and people will be turned away in the
RCMP are well staffed to to address this
if needed I did receive an email on the
weekend that you know Resident was like
let me in or else you know this Convoy
is coming and I'm like
I want to let everybody in Mother Nature
is not cooperating the Highway's on fire
so not sure how the the Convoy would be
looking to to charge through it's
definitely unsafe RCMP say it will
continue to investigate threats of a
convoy it believes is in the planning
stages people are tired they want to be
home but it's really important that
people not try to go home until they're
called until it's time because not only
do you put yourself at risk you're
actually putting our First Responders at
risk the territories Premier is once
again urging patients but it is clearly
starting to run thin
Jamie dog Global News Calgary
the federal government's released a
progress report on meeting
recommendations made earlier this year
by the Rulo commission that's the
inquiry that looked into the
government's response to the disruptive
Convoy protests of early 2022 and
included whether the use of the
emergencies Act was justified you'll
remember the demonstrations paralyzed
the nation's capital and cross-border
traffic in multiple provinces our chief
political correspondent David Aiken
joins us now David what action has the
government taken so far
well far you'll remember that just as
Paul roulo said the Trudeau government
was right to invoke the emergencies act
but he flagged plenty of problems with
the way police and security agencies
dealt with the protests and he called
for better coordination between Ottawa
the provinces and some municipalities
now the federal government released a
progress report on its response to
Rule's recommendations and six months in
the work is still very much at the
beginning stages while it's pretty thin
uh there isn't much substantive uh in
this report uh it just says we're you
know ongoing this is ongoing and that is
ongoing discussions are continuing 26 of
the 57 recommendations Rulo made had to
do with policing reform the government
says the RCMP has started discussions on
that but there's nothing specific yet
Rulo recommended changes to the
emergencies act itself especially
tightening up the definition of a
National Emergency the government says
it is considering such changes Transport
Canada was told develop an inventory of
critical trade corridors and Emergency
Management plans Public Safety Minister
Dominic LeBlanc said well the work has
started and it goes on lots of
consultations lots of discussions policy
papers in the works the government's
final response to the roulette
commission uh presumably with more
details is due in February and in the
meantime the criminal trials for two of
the Convoy leaders Tamara Leach and
Chris Barber well those trials begin
next week right here in the nation's
capital Farah thanks David
police in New Zealand are investigating
deaths that could be connected to a
Canadian man accused of selling lethal
substances to people at risk of
self-harm New Zealand's Coroner's Court
confirmed the deaths are possibly linked
to Kenneth law for Mississauga Ontario
they didn't disclose how many deaths in
that country could be tied to the 57
year old in this country its alleged law
ran several websites selling sodium
nitrites he was arrested in May and he
faces a total of 14 charges here
investigators also allege law sent at
least 1200 packages to more than 40
countries including the UK Australia and
New Zealand
remembering lives lost in a crisis
coming up how heartbroken Canadians are
marking International overdose Awareness
Day
[Music]
want to hear the click before you pull
that syringe out
British Columbians lined up for a free
naloxone training event today it was
aimed at teaching hundreds of people how
to use the life-saving drug during a
possible overdose the event falls on
International overdose awareness day a
day meant to remember those who have
lost their lives and been affected by
the opioid crisis now although record
overdose numbers are seen in several
Canadian jurisdictions per capita
British Columbia Remains the hardest hit
since the province declared a public
health emergency in 2016 more than 12
700 lives have been lost to toxic drugs
between January and July of this year BC
saw
1455 deaths the most ever recorded in
the first seven months of a calendar
year as Nita Garcia reports Advocates
say not nearly enough is being done to
prevent these deaths
foreign
with locks for their lost loved ones and
their images on display at this
Vancouver Beach I lost my my eldest son
Jordan very sadly he was given pure
Fentanyl and he passed away in August
2018 25 years old we need to help people
see no these people are people like us
they were all worth saving and they
could have been saved as BC is on track
for its deadliest year for overdose
deaths this is one of several events
held across the country for
international overdose awareness day she
left
three kids Behind three sons in Toronto
a candlelight vigil as people in
Peterborough pause to remember those who
died of toxic drug poisoning
and an awareness walk in Halifax all
this comes as First Nations are
applauding a U.S Supreme Court decision
to pause and review Purdue pharma's
bankruptcy plan which would Shield the
manufacturer of the highly addictive
opioid painkiller Oxycontin from
lawsuits and accountability the
settlement would have meant that no one
else in the world could sue the
shacklers or Purdue or anything it would
have been like done deal get out of jail
free card you know pass this family is
earning a million dollars a day in
interest off of money they've made off
of killing our people Joan Jack is a
lawyer with the class action lawsuit
representing indigenous communities the
Supreme Court of the United States has
on their own requested more information
about what's happening with First
Nations people in Canada
so it's a huge thing an amazing moment
for us to tell our our horrid story you
know of how we've been exploited Jack
says renowned author physician and
addiction expert Dr Gabor mate will
serve as an expert witness in the case
I'm hoping that this will bring some
peace
to some of our families who've lost
loved ones a pursuit of Justice in the
face of a crisis that's claiming more
and more lives every day
Global News Vancouver
still ahead anguish in South Africa
after a deadly fire
[Music]
in South Africa's largest city at least
74 people were killed when a fire
engulfed an abandoned apartment building
the Johannesburg building was deemed
unfit for a living but it was being used
by some of the city's most vulnerable
Crystal commencing Reports
vulnerable migrants people without homes
and children are among the victims
the grief mounting as officials work to
find all of the victims in the
five-story building and identify them
forensic experts say fingerprints can't
be used in many of the cases because the
bodies are so badly burnt the actual
facts Escape was closed so they people
there was a lot of people you know a lot
of people smoke people suffocated a lot
of people die because of the smoke
Witnesses say some resorted to jumping
out of Windows others dropped children
down hoping they'd live my
just hit the window and to throw the
daughter outside they were the people
they just take my they don't own a while
it was what on the air
the building went up in Flames just
after 1am Thursday it's owned by the
city of Johannesburg it had been a
women's shelter but closed politicians
say cartels are cramming vulnerable
people into derelict buildings and
charging rents these people who are in
these buildings can afford to pay yes
therefore government must create a stock
for Renta because that is Affordable as
many as 200 families may have been
living in the abandoned building I'm
still alive
the cause of the fire is not yet known
Crystal commencing Global News London
[Music]
next Amanda Nebraska gets pulled over
for buck
[Music]
there was no place like Nebraska last
night the state's University now lays
claim to the world record for largest
attendance at a women's sporting event
and what a spectacle
000 three people crammed into Memorial
Stadium for the Corn Huskers volleyball
match against rival Omaha the atmosphere
was electric and it was a three-set
suite for the home team the Husker
volleyball program holds the NCAA record
for consecutive regular season game
sellouts at 306.
thanks
also in Nebraska take a look at this
it's not the kind of car horns most
people think about a driver modified his
vehicle removing part of the roof to
make room for his bull to ride shotgun
the bull's name is Howdy Doody and he's
a popular attraction at local parades
and fairs police though not amused they
pulled over the duo howdy Duty's owner
was written up with a warning asking him
to take his bovine buddy back home
and that's global national for this
Thursday night I'm far right now sir
thank you for spending part of your
evening with us we leave you tonight
with scenes from around the world of
last night's super blue moon a
combination of two rare lunar events it
was a super moon because it's full
during the closest point in its orbit
around the Earth appearing bigger and
brighter than a typical full moon and
also a blue moon that refers to it being
the second full moon in a month Nita
garcha will be at the anchor desk
tomorrow have a good night
[Music]
thank you